emmanuel 22 ans et au régime petit
déjeuner ils ne mangent que des céréales
tous les enfants bientôt dans un
supermarché parce que tout à coup qu'ils
ont de soi quoi tout leur a offert et
puis c'est un peu magique
dépendent
non non mais je garde toujours un côté
très enfants
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien et céréales parce que ça me
met en forme car moi je le matin et puis
après
j'en mange le soir je mange deux fois
dans la journée
mais c'est aussi une alimentation qui me
convient bien de vous c'est toujours
pareil
maintenant le goût change à chaque fois
et puis on peut ajouter des fruits on
peut ajouter du miel peut ajouter
en fait tout ce qui est produit naturel
puisque c'est des céréales ça doit bien
se marier avec tout ce qui tout ce qui
pousse quoi comme angers grande quantité
par jour
du coup j'en mange c'est un bon repas de
céréales le matin
swart en mange beaucoup dijon 2-3 ap les
différentes manches pour coup dur oui
mon père adore la viande et toi tu aimes
bien le vin rouge je peux pas dire que
je n'aime pas mais
mais je crois que je pourrais m'en
passer parce que
c'est quand on commence à manger trop de
viande on devient rouge
ça c'est quelqu'un qui mange beaucoup de
viande mais en fait il est très touchant
parce qu'il en veut encore quoi il veut
toujours manger l'avion il est tout
rouge parce qu'il a beaucoup de sens
c'est vrai mais j'ai l'impression que on
est ce que l'on mange
quand tu manges tu te retrouves pas les
autres autour d' attaques
de la famille oui oui
bon c'est vrai que c'est un repas
solitaire
[Musique]